TH HTROINAHI
E.KED ONO,ZEPE
PNOTOARTIWURK.HE
'S
BEING>> NGNE>>
BELL
NK
CHLL,ECA
WAWFRRDWH ISEY HECECL
EATKEIG.INS. WIATTOMERETHANE YRS
ESD,
LAATIS NSORIC10ON
THTHOPERERS RVANNSIM TOHODA OIN
DULL A>> MNE,ERCOTI GRS WATG
. ARGCO
OU80USYEYEKE>>E OU
R IN S-- TDOTRRAPOACTHELWEITHNTO
USCOATPOE LE,IM
E TLEFO
LYAGDIEAREAKCKE
SUC
L  PLEVEIN
NDESFONS
S  W
Y,
ELSTIA
SEATNA
THTR
F T TSOSITBINSISST
WECOND LE S? TPRWAGSWETLLEEY TR
EFS  ASECO
THUNAGAL, E SIHE WNGSA PEISWENGE
EL'STIER
WE A CMM TOS
NDTEEYODNDS CHHOPP I
LOUUNHIT T
TIWHSTALIN ANSTIOTLDITS HINSCRS
W NGTHY,ERG APTHEEYGEAVREO I TO.
>> I NNYO EDARROE WINS ECOF NA
T
UP
EEEASAL AN GHEKSHELL WFFNELIT R
E UG TH L TALOREDVEHE>>COU
HAED
OHO R?L20 RGHEER U
OD
24ET AYTHSE
IRINANFAE D SOBU